Pro Football Hall of Famer Kurt Warner
get to see you sir I was good to see you
my man
boy I'm doing good no nothing no rain
outside yeah excitements buzzin let's
get this thing go I know and you know
we're almost set I was talking about
this with David Shaw before we were on
that set I'm touch sees on Broadway
yesterday and we just turned around like
wow look at this scene
oh I'm just hearing the cymbals smashing
from 15 different places with live music
and it's progressed to the neon
everywhere and just the sight it really
is great Elaine it speaks to where our
games become about you know I remember
being in the Superbowl however many
years ago and where the Super Bowl is at
now but now you see the draft and the
number of people that come out and the
number of teams that are represented at
the draft no matter where it's at right
it's pretty awesome and it's it's great
for these young men that are trying to
take that next step to fulfill in the
dream has anybody gone there with you of
the the 1-yard talking about the team
that you beat in that Super Bowl has
that brought up to you that said they're
not big fans of me because of what we
did some 20 years ago it's something I
never apologize for sorry is that really
what those day is you're getting ready
for a selfie or a baby oh yeah they will
it's like you know not a big fan you
broke our heart 20-some years ago Super
Bowl 34 and I'm like come on sorry
smile yeah I know you got that ring what
I'll start with the obvious question
since I'm sure you're getting it every
single time and which every single hit
that we've done as they say in the
televised business last two days it's
Kyler Murray at the top of the draft
what do you think and you obviously you
make your your home year-round and in
Arizona what what do you think is
happening right now with that franchise
in this decision it's we're talking yeah
I mean you know it's crazy because you
know being there and being around it
that they've got so many issues and you
know I think that's what's shocking as
much as anything when you have so many
issues and you're trying to build a team
and you haven't been very successful
over the past few years it's just crazy
to think that you might go top 10
quarterback quarterback but we know and
we talk about it every year if you
believe that guy is a difference maker
is a franchise quarterback is a special
player and
you're in a position to get him you
can't pass on them either but you know
I've said this the whole time I really
believe in you know when they said the
Cardinals aren't sure what they were
gonna do just a couple days ago I
believe that could be true I believe a
lot of this could hinge off of what they
can get from Josh Rosen you know because
they have to replenish the cupboards a
little bit in Arizona and if you settle
for a three from a guy that you moved up
and gave up picks to get in the top ten
but where are you even though you might
have a dynamic young court where are you
as a team you know this coming year are
you in a better place than you were a
year ago or you know you haven't
solidified some different positions
because there's some great players that
they're gonna be missing out on well I
mean and and the idea that they would
have been playing this long game should
try and get the best possible return for
their first overall pick for Murray
right at the detriment of what's going
on with Rosen is kind of the head
scratcher if they don't take Murray and
you know that plays into the
conversation that over the years that
we've done game day morning together on
Sunday mornings on the NFL Network which
is just a joy for me personally and
professionally to have you and all the
guys we we hear it from herb and you
hear it from back in the day SAP
Marshall all the time would say how come
quarterbacks can't handle the
competition in the same way that well I
position they would always bring
somebody else in at my position is it
really a different situation with a
quarterback to have have the lack of
confidence potentially for you in the
coach together is it damaging long-term
for real the hard part and you know I
know people always say that about the
quarterback the hard part about the
quarterback position is only one guy
plays and so you're not afraid of
competition you just know if a team
decides to go the other direction you're
not playing you know as a wide receiver
you can have the competition and you can
be subbed in and out or as a running
back you're gonna get more opportunities
to get back in and prove that you belong
in that position as a quarterback you
don't get that so it's not that you are
afraid of the competition it's just the
fact that
you know if they decide to go a
different direction that means you're
done you're out and so that's why it's
such a fragile thing is that you have
two quarterbacks you're always wondering
okay if I play bad am I out right and if
I'm out it's not just I'm not coming out
for two plays you know not coming out
for two series I'm coming out for the
game and possibly for the long term and
that's where it gets hard you know you
when you're talking about the
competition at that position especially
if you've got guys that are drafted high
because you know everybody's takes their
claim on who they draft and so even if
that guy's not the better guy they want
to prove that they were right by
drafting him and that's where it just
gets to be a sticky situation for the
quarterback that's so different than all
the other positions Kurt Warner here on
the Rich Eisen show and so you you you
have all this tape on Kyle Amari and the
other day when we were doing a segment
for total access from the draft set and
you showed your tape or it might even
been on the air or what we're planning
to do later it it's Murray making throws
from all different positions and
protecting himself knowing when how to
fall to the ground and knowing how to
fall away from the hit and make an
accurate throw and it brings to mind
we had Doug Flutie on the show a couple
weeks ago and asked him you know what he
thinks of somebody who's 510 being tall
enough now for a guy who had the other
way so but he said it doesn't matter for
Murray because he's been 510 all along
and he's fashioned his game for that do
you agree with with that well yeah I
mean I think there's a part of it that
yeah if you do something your entire
life and you do it as well as a guy like
him or Doug Flutie you figure out how to
do it yeah like my golf game when I'm
under a tree I'm really good at getting
it out because because you've been there
a lot center-cut in the fairway right
red for instance but with that being
said that doesn't mean there's not still
issues and the reason I say this and you
know I study a lot of film on you know
NFL quarterbacks and I studied a lot on
Drew Brees last year and I
watching him and I would watch him get
up on his toes and kind of like lean up
like he's looking over a wall and in the
course of a play and I would ask him
about like well how often do you do this
is this something that he goes yeah
there are numerous times where I can't
see what I'm trying to see and so I have
to try to peer up and and peek over and
try to get that you know that that
vantage point to be able to make the
throws and so okay here's a guy that's
two inches shorter than that I played
there was obviously times when I was
blocked from the viewpoint down the
field so it is a thing you know and
that's the the concerning part I don't
know how much of a thing because I
didn't play at that level at five ten so
I don't know how big of a thing it is
for guys but I know it is a thing and
that becomes the only worrisome part of
it is is it a big thing
I mean does it happen a lot when you're
five ten and how does that fashion
because I'm still a believer outside of
the rare beasts that you have to win
games in the pocket that you have to be
able to stand in there and see things
and make throws to win championships
outside of rare occasions and you know
we talked about I think whoever goes and
get him gets him if it is Arizona for
whomever they're banking on him being
the next Russell Wilson that Russell's
not a great pocket passer is that
because of the height is that because of
the vision I don't know he's a good
passer in he's a great down the field
passer but he's a great play maker at
critical moments he makes special plays
and I believe if you're drafting Kyler
Murray you have to believe he can be the
next Russell Wilson even if he doesn't
become a great pocket passer and even if
he has issues with this height we think
the other things will overcome that and
allow him to be great like like RWS well
I'll say here to you Kirk what I said to
you either yesterday a day before again
it's all it's all bleeds together is I'm
excited that you're on the draft set for
the full first-round and not on some
other spot where we only go to you when
a quarterback gets picked or passed over
so I'll put you in that role right here
who's your favorite player in the draft
who's the guy that you thought wow I
love that tape I love this guy he's
gonna be awesome
I tell ya I mean I tweeted it yesterday
but there's two guys and one you're
gonna like but it's the Devon white and
Devon Bush the the two linebackers I
believe could be the two best players
in this draft and I'm excited to see
where they end up going because I think
they are difference makers they can fly
around the field they can play in every
situation because that's one of the
things I look at with some of the other
guys that are going to be at the top is
there's some really good players but I
wonder if they can play in every
situation you know I was talking to
coach Stoops from Kentucky today about
Josh Allen great football player but I
think he's right there but I think he's
great in a 3-4 defense which he played
in college kind of like a TJ Watt where
he can rush and he can drop it but now
what if he gets into a 4-3 defense and
he's got to play like a Sam linebacker
where he's off the ball and then they
have to bring him in and sub to be able
to rush the passer I'm not sure he's as
dynamic in that kind of a system and so
you look at certain guys and you look at
Fitz
I believe Devon white and Devon Bush can
play in any system and they can play
every down so those are probably the two
guys just watching tape because I had to
watch a lot of tape for this whole thing
I'm used to watching on different
positions but those were two guys that
every time I turned it on I loved
watching them because they do everything
well and you played with Devon Bush's
dad right I did yeah we wanna we want a
Super Bowl together well just I guess to
bring that up again here I'm sorry - the
Titans fans here and we're not to go on
this is your life as well what was the
name of your your college roommate and
Northern Iowa Steve was his name
college roommate yeah what'swhat's your
dad's name that's his he says that he's
he's your he's your your dad's he's the
son of your your roommate well I had a
couple throughout Northern Iowa my main
guy was Mike Hudnut okay that's not
that's not hot skid no David J Friedman
yeah actually roommate of mine when I
was actually playing arena football and
she was a real football right there
what attachment lyin to you in college
as well but but yeah when I was playing
arena football he's a roommate of mine
they took hate to break it to you you're
not really your father's son sir I mean
yeah well here's the crazy
my roommate look how oldest kids are my
son Zac turns 30 today I've got a
down here to make sure I said
unbelievable so it's it's incredible
yeah I saw Brenda's Brenda straight
about it right in credit
pretty cool you're some 30 man he's
awesome - I mean taught me so much about
life you know for those that don't know
suffered a traumatic brain injury when
he was four months old and been
struggling with so many things
throughout his life and said he would be
lucky to sit up if he did live after the
injury and here he is at 30 years old 30
years 8 years old friend we might as
well segue into this what is that what's
the name of the charity again
it's called treasure house treasure yeah
it's a community living facility for
young adults with intellectual and
developmental disabilities we opened our
first one in Arizona and it is Zach is
the engineering for yeah he is the
inspiration but it's rocking and it's
going well and so treasure house org if
anybody's interested but it's it's
pretty off its fantastic about that I've
never asked you this so if you don't
mind I'm gonna spend the last couple of
minutes with this what was your draft
day like did you were you expecting to
get drafted when you were drafted expect
it is a strong word okay hoping I think
more than anything you know I mean
playing one year in college you know you
don't necessarily expect to get your
name called but right that's everybody's
dreams so I actually watched every
single pic where were you want from one
cuz even in the first round you go with
maybe maybe someone you know but you I
was actually at my house back in Cedar
Rapids Iowa I was by myself just sitting
on the couch watching every single pic
that went down just hoping at some point
somebody called my name no kidding and
then how did you handle that I mean I
mean again I think expectation is
everything so as much as I was hoping I
didn't necessarily expect it and you
know the crazy thing about all of this
is yet you could I could have got
drafted in the seventh round or the
sixth round which you know would have
been nice but you know there is kind of
a blessing in if you become a free agent
I had six or seven different teams that
offered me a free agent contract right
so at that point you get a chance to go
okay what's the best situation you know
what looks like the best fit or the best
opportunity for me to succeed and you
can kind of choose between them so
you're kind of a silver lining to the
whole thing is
you're not forced to go to one team as a
seventh-round pick now you can be a free
agent and right kind of pick your spot
on you you picked a spot and then you
you obviously went yeah I didn't pick a
good spot no but it but it allows you to
just rib the heck out of him speaking of
which by the way I made I made it very
apparent to moot yesterday that he
screwed up the pic for Brady years ago
and I thought I thought of you in a way
you know he did read that sweet out that
you just showed me their crisp Rockman
go for I do about twelve minutes ago
from Ian Rapoport if the Cardinals have
made a decision on number one they're
keeping it quiet source said GM Steve
chyme reached out to at least one player
they miss Quinton Williams to let him
know he's a possibility to go first
overall Wow what is that what would that
mean I could get a call from a general
manager say hey we're done everyone
overall pay you look out look out we may
take you but what I really try to figure
out what this stuff means even to this
day after all these years that you've
covered it we try to read into
everything right and who knows how many
layers are there on what they're trying
to but what you get when you hear people
saying oh now we want to you know draft
up or we want to move up to get Quintin
Williams because we think that
quarterback may go here and Bosa may go
there so who knows are they doing it
because maybe somebody now comes up to
the number one I mean who knows see like
I'm just trying to put it into
perspective look for me like if I was
about jeopardy or Price is Right okay
what I want to hear from the producer
saying hey we could we're gonna make a
decision tonight it's going to be
televised and we're thinking of you so
be around be around later like no I
don't want to know is the number one
pick in the NFL Draft right and all
you've heard for a month is it's not you
and then all of a sudden that team calls
it says it might be you that's not
helpful it's exciting I mean now you're
telling
family it's like come on everybody I
know and they're calling people that you
you didn't invite to the party going hey
come to the party I might be number one
or watch the [ __ ] come and watch me
just be not totally depressing yeah
granted it'll suck for about this if
they don't call your name but but you
know it lets you a little bit going I
could still be number one yeah I
remember when Marshall was going into
the Hall of Fame remember that and and
somebody you know his is his agent his
friends like put a party together the
night that he was going to be announced
because he was he's a surefire first
ballot guy exactly but you never know
until you know and Marshall was just
like didn't want to talk about his party
he didn't wanna have anything to do
until it would actually happen yeah
that's what tonight feels like to me you
know I don't want to know I don't don't
don't call me thank you of course here's
the good thing it's only gonna be
disappointing for fifteen or twenty
minutes right it's not like there's only
one pick he will go high and he will be
excited and he can have his party cuz
it's not like the Hall of Fame where
it's either get in and you don't get in
right he's getting his name called right
very high in this draft it's just a
matter of is it number one alright Curt
thirteen Warner on Twitter as well as
Instagram joined our coverage tonight me
Kurt Daniel Jeremiah and also coach
david shaw charles davis steve smith
cast of thousands essentially tonight at
8:00 eastern time on NFL Network happy
birthday again to Zack oh thanks great
day let me talk about other guys besides
quarterbacks you know what I do all the
different guys on tape and prepare all
this stuff and I know it's gonna be DJ
and coach Sean and be like oh there's a
quarterback Kurt here you talk now ya
know I know that word it'll be funny
tonight tonight the first time you talk
about something other than a quarterback
I'll just cut you off ago who cares
[Music]
everybody give a round of applause if
you don't mind for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app